I'm joined today by Peter gray who is a
research professor of psychology at
Boston College and also author of the
book free to learn why releasing the
instinct to play will make our children
happier more self-reliant and better
students for life Peter we've been
talking a lot about the changing
dynamics of the economy job automation
proposals around basic income etc and
one of the conversations that is sort of
part of that that is often less
discussed is how would people be
affected in a sort of socio-cultural way
if all of a sudden the need to work were
eliminated so let's start there I've
read some of what you've written about
this you think that there may be a
pretty significant newfound sort of
boredom and apathy that might in in fact
society no I think quite the opposite I
think there would be some people who
might be bored and apathetic because the
play has been drilled out of them people
haven't had that that instinct that we
have to find interesting and fun things
to do has been kind of drilled out of
them by the work of school by the work
of of their jobs and careers but it's
pretty natural to human beings to want
to do interesting things and find great
things to do and if we had the time to
do it I think there would be a real
flourishing of our humanity of human
nature of flourishing of culture I tend
to agree with that one of the things
I've been thinking of is that really the
last hundred and fifty or 200 years of
sort of Western society have much more
clearly delineated when are we working
and when are we not working and of
course the creation of the factory was a
huge huge factor in that but if we think
back to like hunter-gatherers for
example the lines between what was
working and what was play or
recreational time were much more blurry
weren't they well that's exactly right
and in fact I think it's reasonable to
say you know from an evolutionary
perspective I'm an evolutionary
psychologist so I look at sort of the
long time for
of human existence from an evolutionary
perspective work is kind of a new
invention you know during most of our
human history we were all
hunter-gatherers and its really only
with agriculture and then subsequently
with industry that the idea of labor as
work as something that you don't want to
do but you have to do in order to get
what you need to survive or get the
things that you want that notion of work
is absent in hunter-gatherer
hunter-gatherer bands you know there
have been studies of those groups of
people in various parts of the world who
survived as hunter-gatherers into modern
times and if they have a word for work
at all or a concept of it all it refers
to what those farmers on the other side
of the hill do or those coal miners do
it doesn't refer to what they do and
there was there was even a book
published two or three decades ago maybe
a little longer ago by anthropologist
named Marshall Solon in which he
referred to hunter-gatherer societies in
the original affluent society affluent
not because they had a lot but because
they didn't need much and they had lots
of free time and they spent that free
time at music and art and dance and
storytelling and visiting neighbors and
lying around in the hammock gossiping
doing all the kinds of things that we do
when we're on vacation when we do when
when we're freed up from work it only
takes them about 20 hours a week and the
typical hunter-gatherer culture too to
provide for themselves and even that
they don't regard as work because it's
it's thrilling it's exciting to Hanten
together and they don't have to do it
but you know any individual doesn't have
to do it I would say because they share
everything and they don't complain if
somebody says no I'm not gonna go out
hunting today I
I have friends to visit or a of this or
that to do very different attitude from
ours well there's this sort of idea that
I've heard a few people talk about and
it does make sense to me which is that
in in sort of modern Western
in the pet work paradigm that we have
the amount of work you have to do seems
to be sort of pliable and that it will
often adapt to the amount of time
allocated for it and I think it's very
easy for a lot of people who work sort
of like an office job to imagine how if
you know you're there for an eight or
nine hour day your entire work day will
take eight or nine hours for you to
complete your tasks but if one day you
know you're leaving earlier you're
coming in late and you have five hours
very often you're able to complete the
work that you would normally do in eight
or nine hours in the five or six that
you allocate now this analysis doesn't
apply to shift work where you're
actually there for a particular amount
of time rather than for a particular
number of tasks but shouldn't that tell
us something at least about the concept
that we have about the work week and
work schedules yeah I mean you know
right now this is really an economics
problem of how you know we we're sort of
stuck with a system that to support
yourself you've got to work a certain
number of hours it's not you know one of
the problems we have of course is
there's not really all that much work
that needs to be done these days you
know we've got machines and that takes
very little human effort to grow all the
food we need it takes very little human
effort to produce the clothing and
shelter that we need and so on and so
forth so we're in this ironic situation
where it's easier than ever before to
provide for our needs and yet we're all
working more perhaps than we ever did
before or more than more than more than
we should need to be doing way more than
we should need to be doing that's an
economics problem that's out sort of out
of my field but if we could solve that
economics problem I think that we would
be we would all be much happier we would
we would have a better society we would
rediscover much of our humanity well let
me know a lot more along that line if I
can because there are some people who I
talk to about topics that are either
directly related to this or tangentially
related we'll say you know the problem
is that if we were to set up a system
where there is a basic income or that
everybody's sort of basic needs are met
and health care Bay
food shelter is provided for without
necessarily having to work humans are
just inherently so lazy that most of
them just wouldn't want to do anything
and for most of what I've read that does
not appear to be the case what's your
sense of that this idea that humans
didn't have to work in order to survive
that most of them would choose to do
nothing or to be completely emotionless
I I tend to reject that completely yeah
I mean let me let me give three lines of
evidence that lead me to rejected one is
look at little kids right look at little
kids who are free in those kids who are
free to do what they want before they've
ever started school are they doing are
they just lazy and lied around all day
no they're into things they're looking
for things they're making up stories
they're doing all kinds of things
there's no end to what they want to do I
don't think that that that capacity is
unique to little kids we drill it out of
us when we send our kids to work like
schools and when we go into into this
laborious kind of adult life
that's natural human behavior that we
see in those little kids and we would
all retain that kind of behavior if if
in fact we didn't have it drilled out of
us another line of evidence is the
hunter-gatherer observations that I just
described and here's a third line of
evidence for people who don't know this
book I would recommend this is a classic
work by John housing I'm not sure if I'm
pronouncing his last name correctly
there's a Dutch way of saying that name
called Homo Luden's it's a classic work
Homo Luden's means man the player and
what housing it does in that book is he
analyzes what we think of as high
culture the developments and philosophy
and poetry our music science all the
kinds of things that we value as sort of
great human achievements and he says
we're in what times and places have
there been a flourishing of these things
and his conclusion is it's those times
in places where there is a significant
number of adults who
have the leisure to play and that all of
this is coming out of play all these
things that we think of as the highest
sorts of contributions to to our human
heritage have come you know places like
Athens ancient Athens there were a group
of freemen you know who had time to play
throughout their lives and look at what
they did with that play and there and
housing identifies other points and
places in in history where the same
thing has been true so I think that we
should all look very much forward to a
time when we have the opportunity to
play in adult life according to housing
and we are man the player that's our
nature that seems to be our nature when
I look at hunter-gatherer cultures - and
we have we've been suppressing that
nature for two or three thousand years
if not longer
and ever since we'd been a so highly
agricultural artist and then and then
industrialized well I I couldn't say
better myself and I tend to be very
skeptical of any argument that is an
argument against an idea based on the
assumption that humans are just going to
be very very lazy and freeriders I mean
you obviously have some element of that
in any system but I don't think it's
it's by and large representative of
human nature we've been speaking with
Professor Peter gray who teaches
psychology at Boston College you can
also check out his book free to learn
thanks so much for talking to me today
I've been very it's been delightful
thank you